this is a little bit of a general
question but uh
almost a bigger picture question that we
touched on a little bit but let's just
touch it in a full way which is uh what
have all the psychedelic studies you've
conducted
taught you about the human mind
about the human brain and the human mind
is there
something if you look at the human
scientists you were before
this work and the scientists you are now
how is your understanding of the human
mind changed
i'm thinking of that in two categories
one kind of more
more scientific and they're both
scientific but
um one more about you know more about
the
the brain and behavior and the mind so
to speak
and as a behaviorist always see sort of
the mind as a metaphor for
behavior so but anyway that gets
philosophical
but it's really increasing the
the so the one category is increasing
the
appreciation for the magnitude of
depth i mean so these are all metaphors
of
of human experience that might be a good
way to because you use certain words
like consciousness
and what and it's like we're using
constructs that aren't well defined
and unless we kind of dig in but into
human experience
like that the experiences on these
compounds
can be so far out there or so deep
and that like and they're doing that by
tinkering with the same machinery that's
going on up there i mean i'm
my assumption and i think it's a good
assumption is that all
experiences you know there's a there's a
biological side
to all phenomenal experience
you know so there is not you know the
divide between biology
you know and and um
and experience or psychology is
is it's you know it's not one or the
other these are just two
you know two sides of the same coin
i mean you're avoiding the the word the
use of the word consciousness for
example but the experience is referring
to
the subjective experience so it's it's
the actual technical use of the word
consciousness of
of yeah yeah subjective experience and
even that word
there are certain ways that like like
sort of like if we're talking about
access
consciousness or narrative
self-awareness which is an aspect of
like you can wrap a definition around
that we can talk meaningfully about it
but so often around psychedelics it's
used in this much more
in terms of ultimately explaining
phenomenal consciousness itself the
so-called hard problem
and you know uh relating to that
question and
psychedelics really haven't spoken to
that and
that's why it's hard because like it's
hard to imagine anything but i think
what i was getting is that
psychedelics have done this by the
reason i was getting into the biology
versus mind
psychology divide is that that
just to kind of set up the fact that i
think all of our experience
is related to these
biological events so whether they be
naturally occurring neurotransmitters
like serotonin and dopamine and
norepinephrine etc
and a whole other sort of biological
activity and kind of
another layer up that we could talk
about network activity
communication amongst brain areas like
this is always going on
even if i just prompt you to think about
a loved one
you know like there's something
happening biologically
okay so that's always another side of
the coin so
another way to put that is all of our
subjective experience outside of drugs
it's it's all a controlled hallucination
in a sense it like this is completely
constructed
our our experience of reality is
completely
a simulation so i i think we're on on
solid ground to say that that's our best
guess and that's a pretty reasonable
thing to
to say scientifically like all the rich
complexity of the world emerges from
just some biology and some chemicals
so in that you know in that that
definition imply to causation it comes
from
and so that's right that's we know at
least there's a solid correlation there
and so then we don't dig we delve deep
into the philosophy of like idealism or
materialism and things like this which
i'm not an expert in but i know we're
getting into that
territory you don't even necessarily
have to go
there like you you at least go to the
level of like okay we know there's there
seems to be this one-on-one
correspondence
and that seems pretty silent like you
can't prove a negative and you can't
you know it's in that category of like
yeah me you could come up with an
experience that maybe doesn't have a
biological correlate
but then you're talking about there's
also the limits of the science so is it
a false negative but
i think our best guess and a very decent
assumption is that
every psychological event has a
biological correlate
so with that said you know the idea that
you can throw alter that biology
in a pretty trivial manner i mean you
could take like
a relatively small number of these
molecules throw them into the nervous
system
and then have a a 60 year old person
who has he you name it i mean that has
hiked to the top of everest and that
speaks five languages
and that has been married and has kids
and grandkids
and has you name you know like been at
the top and say
this fundamentally changed who i am as a
person
and and the and what i think life is
about
like that's that's the thing about
psychedelics that just floors me and it
it never fails i mean sometimes you get
bogged down by the paperwork and
running studies and all the i don't know
all of the
the bs that can come with being in
academia and everything and then you
and sometimes you get some dud sessions
where it's not the fullness all the
magic isn't happening and it's you know
more or less it's or it's either a dud
or somewhere and
i don't mean to dismiss them but you
know it's it's not like these
magnificent sort of reports but
sometimes you get the full monty
report from one of these people and
you're like oh yeah that's why we're
doing this whether it's like
therapeutically or just to understand
the mind and you're like
you're still floored like how is that
possible
how did we slightly alter serotonergic
neurotransmission
and say and this person is now saying
that they're they're
they're making fundamental differences
in the in the priorities of their life
after 60 years it also just fills you
with
uh all of the
possibility of experiences were yet to
have uncovered if if just a few
chemicals can change
so much it's like man
what if this could be up i mean like ha
because we're just like took a little
like it's like lighting a match or
something in the darkness and you can
see there's a lot more there but you
don't know
how much more and that's right
you